all right guys
bang bang i've got ross here super
excited about this
uh you may win the award for the most
number of questions i've had to send in
so uh welcome thank you for doing this
most of it was heckling i'm sure
well you you also cheated just so
everyone knows when i asked for the
questions i tagged the person on twitter
but you started answering the questions
in the comments i didn't realize you
know
i saw the questions i get excited you
know i love it
i love that people are engaged with
finance you know it's a it's a lonely
thing in my household because my wife
doesn't care at all
she doesn't follow the stock market she
doesn't care what i do
um she cares if if i was losing probably
but
but
um but it's great to see so many people
in the public that's why i like twitter
interested in the stock market it's what
i love you know it's fun
absolutely so for the couple of people
who are watching who don't know who you
are let's start with just a
introduction on yourself and then kind
of walk us through your background and
how we get to uh
gerber kawasaki well i don't want to
take the whole
podcast up with my life story
but basically you know i i was fortunate
i grew up in a household where my mom
was an investor and my grandfather was
an investor
so when i was a kid i would go over to
my grandfather's
uh condo in marina del rey and they were
not rich okay
they like were now in hindsight kind of
like
middle lower class in a way but but my
grandfather wanted to be retired
so he had this nice little apartment in
marina del rey would play golf and he
would sail and
and i thought it was the best life of
the world compared to my dad who worked
like 12 hours a day and he's a dentist
and
you know i was like grandpa how do you
do this it's better than dad you know
um so he would show me you know these
stocks he would own which were basically
in the 70s and 80s were like utilities
and military companies that would like
pay high dividends
um so he taught me about dividends and
buy and hold and all this kind of stuff
but then
when i was a kid my mom would get me to
save like i worked as a waiter when i
was uh
16 that was my first job it was it was
great i was in bel air working at this
pizza place for a guy named george santa
pietro
and if you look him up boy there's
stories around this guy right
and i was in the middle of it as a 16
year old but i was making money
80s you know and uh so my mom made me
invest and i i
she said give me the cash we'll buy
stocks and i bought disney
she taught me to buy disney i i started
following it
um so then concurrently i've always
played music so i'm a musician and so
when i got to college i i went to
university of pennsylvania
and i thought i was going to go to
wharton be a business major but
i started taking classes there i really
didn't like it and um
there were also no girls in the classes
so i was i was pretty much
i'm not gonna do this so so i went to
communications which i liked a lot more
and there were
females in those classes um and
during college i started trading stocks
and it was like
92-93 so it was post-91 recession so
things were starting to get better
and the dow was at 3 000 at the time and
i remember
when the market rallied 30 points i was
happy so when i graduated from college
i got into the investment industry
because the
music industry which i had i worked at
atlantic records and geffen for a little
bit
for a couple months and then i was like
this is going to collapse because of
technology
because of napster and all that and i
was like meeting with people and they
were like look
kid you don't know what you're talking
about so i decided to get into financial
services because i was writing
newsletters to people lawyers
friends of my parents about
entertainment stocks and they're like
you just can't do this you have to get a
license
so i ended up getting licensed through
an independent investment firm called
sun america securities which was
here in los angeles was run by a guy
named eli brode
who was a genius and this other guy
jay wintrop ran sun america and
they were super smart and they saw the
coming retirement wave
and so we sold retirement products
that's how i learned i sold iras i sold
mutual funds
so when i was 23 i was like selling
mutual funds and
and you know basically making phone
calls you know
um and and so it grew from there you
agree from there
but i learned um in the 90s
um what i always believe which is that
technology is the best thing we do in
america and
if you invest in technology you have the
best opportunity to build wealth
and because i naturally understood
technology and i
loved consumer technology i was able to
find investments at the time whether it
was dell or
gateway or aol aol was kind of my first
big score
you know i was really able to figure out
that if we
if i could see what was happening and
invest in those things
you could make much higher returns so
that worked out obviously very well in
the 90s so
to fast forward to the financial crisis
so i was working for the sun america
firm
and by the time i was 28 i was i was
managing
250 employees in 15 offices
for sun america we were like a regional
firm within sun america
so somehow i was responsible for a lot
of people
um by the time i was 28 and
we were doing pretty well and then the
fight and then we had com
and dot bust and then fast forward to
the financial crisis so after the
financial crisis
i me and my partner were like
[ __ ] all this you know [ __ ] aig
[ __ ] you know uh jp morgan
we're gonna start our own firm because
these people
they're so greedy they they put us all
and our clients all at risk
you know and it was a nightmare so i i
got i lost
pretty much everything in financial
crisis i was i was down to like
70 000 and uh
and then i had put i bought a house and
then at the low
my house caught on fire so in december
of 08
for real december of oa my house was on
fire
i had i was down in my last couple bucks
i didn't have debts thank god but i had
a couple properties i lost to
and i was like dude this sucks you know
this really sucks so i decided to start
a firm that seems like a horrible idea
too
but um but i figured and my partner
figured
that if we if this was the beginning of
the rebound this would be ideal time to
start a firm
because new firms would be born and we
would hire a whole new set of young
advisors
and just redo this industry digitally so
that was sort of our innovation
was well we're small but we can look big
digitally
and so we built a website we were the
first firm on facebook we're the first
firm on yelp we're the first firm on
instagram we're the first firm
to use all these social media tools and
we used to get
i used to get in a lot of trouble
actually but then one day the sec
was like well we want to make rules will
you help us make rules
so we were in the pilot program for
facebook with the sec this was about 10
years ago
and so by leveraging social media
we've been able to build a huge firm and
and still growing like crazy um
and we're still doing it and so our goal
is to democratize financial advice
you know be able to provide people no
matter what their background is
financial advice um from young people
who have their first jobs to millennials
who are now
buying houses and get married to baby
boomers who are
trying to figure out how to earn
interest in the zero percent world so
um and we've been very successful being
an independent firm fiduciary
we pick stocks which is also rare um so
our philosophy is index plus alpha so we
use indexes we build around indexes with
our
with our stock picks and we only focus
in stocks in areas like technology where
we're experts
so areas that i'm not an expert like
biotechnology um we own the indexes
you know i can't tell you if more dairna
is going to have a better vaccine than
pfizer
you know i just am not qualified to do
that but i own them all
you know but i can tell you what i think
about zoom and docusign
and where uh spotify is going and
you know whether apple has a great
strategy and that that's where we focus
on the stock picking side so that's
that's the life story got it and so when
you went to start the firm i think that
um like you said there was pretty much
nobody on social media even in
2018 like social media was kind of just
even starting
it was starting yeah right and so kind
of why
focus on the digital platforms and then
when you talk about you would get in
trouble in the beginning like what were
you guys doing and kind of
how did the regulators look at this and
all of that
so so part of it was like
we came from south america which was big
and then they were bought by aig
and we used to be like where with aig
they were triple a rated
a dow stock how safe could you be
right so when that all falls apart
you're like why don't we just
start a new firm because nobody cares
about merrill lynch or aig anymore i
don't think anybody
invests with merrill lynch thinking like
this is some big solid company
because they've gone out of business
already once you know they were safe
it's bank of america really right um so
we were like how do we look big and how
do we get to lots of people
when we don't have an ad budget and you
know
i you know i started the company with
like my own money like we didn't we
don't have private equity
we don't have vcs uh we don't have high
tower or you know some backer
you know we're we're gerber kawasaki and
and so
like i came up with my own dough we
started the company i wasn't making any
money you know
i i was getting paid for my other
company uh to leave basically
and and uh so that helped me survive for
the first two years where i
basically didn't make any money because
we went from commissions to advisory
that was the other
innovation that not innovation but
strategic change we made was we sold
products and earned commissions through
a broker dealer
and then in 2003 i started doing
advisory and i was like this is a better
way
except you make a lot less money you
know on the short term
and so when we started gk i knew it
would take five years
just to make it worth it to switch from
advisory uh from commissions to advisory
but i knew over time that would pay off
and and boy has it
you know boy i i don't know how people
survive selling products now you know
um so going back to social media how
could we get big
so we sat in a room when facebook was
pretty new and back then if you shared a
post your friends actually saw it
remember and like it was actually all
your friends on facebook so
facebook started it was really cool like
what they've turned this into
is a disaster but like when it started
it was really cool so like the first day
we all sat in our room and we shared it
and and i didn't really have any fans
because i was older so you know
like any friends on facebook i was like
my friends are like figuring this out
too
um but in the first day we got a
thousand fans and i was like wow
you know like this works like we just
shared it and people followed our firm
and so we started posting
but our compliance department not the
regulators
stopped us immediately they're like what
are you doing well it took them a little
bit
time to figure out what we were doing
and i said well what's the difference
between this and you know i don't know
sending out a letter or you know or or
doing a a
seminar you know they say well because
you got to pre-approve everything and
whatever
so we started doing that we would
pre-approve our posts
in advance for like a week so i write
posts for a week send it to compliance
they would say
yes or no and then we would post and and
ironically when the financial crisis
this was pre-gk actually
but when the financial crisis happened
they fired the entire compliance
department
at sun america so i was like yes you
know like nobody's going to chat for
years you know
and that was true actually so so
ironically like
nobody checked us for like two years
okay
that we were just able to function on
social media without compliance and then
aig got all these like people that
started running aig for the government
and i was like okay the gig is up now
you know
and this lady calls me from head of
compliance for aig
and she said i see what you're doing and
i was like all right the gig's up and
she's like no
we want to use you in the pilot program
with with with uh finra and scc
because you're the only one doing this
and actually
you know this is going to happen and
they were actually really smart people
the people the government brought into
aig to save it
did a great job you know and and so they
were like just keep doing this and let's
make up rules and so we
did that uh with the sec and and this at
this time aig and we helped create
the standards that they use today um
but that being said um we were able to
reach the our
target market which was younger upwardly
mobile people
better on social media than traditional
media
i use traditional media too so you know
i'm big in traditional media and i've
used that but what i've found
in my career is almost nobody watches
financial television
but millions of people are on twitter
facebook
instagram and they do consume financial
content
that way and it's very effective and so
we continue to do it and we continue to
innovate with this with live streams and
other things
now and now we can't even see our
clients so
from zoo webinars to to we've moved our
business completely virtual and we were
already prepared to do it
but we've had like the most seamless
transition to virtual
like i could have dreamed of because we
were already so far
but now we're back in the office and
stuff but we're continuing to use all
the digital tools so
so i guess you could call us almost like
a hybrid digital firm now
um but it's been working people like
working with people i don't think these
digital solutions are
are the panacea that everybody wants so
so yeah it's been super good
and and it feels like when you were
early on social media it really was kind
of the outbound communication fill the
top of the funnel with people who could
potentially be clients
and that was kind of how you guys did it
rather than direct mail or
any sort of other type of outreach that
other firms would do or were you also
doing kind of the more traditional
outreach along with social no
no so like the whole idea of our firm
like a hundred percent is digital
like they're like where's your brochure
it's our website like we had an argument
the other day because they
these guys wanted to make a brochure for
ultra high net worth clients blah blah
blah i go you think they're going to
read a piece of paper
you know even these old people look at
websites you know and and
and our printers hated us you know
because we used to print tons of stuff
and i go sorry buddy you know
and and i just had a bunch of young guys
ask me for business cards i was like
you guys want business cards like you
can't even see people let alone
like give a business card out you know
um
so so the idea of our firm and where we
make
margin was leveraging social media is a
lot cheaper than traditional advertising
it just is and then you know using pr
and getting tv spots is a lot cheaper
than tv commercials which we're actually
running tv commercials now
because i do want to run stuff on the
lakers so
um we have some nice commercials that we
made for the for lakers so god willing
will have some sports
you know um but
i think that's the genius of social
media you've done this too you've built
your whole
uh podcast and you have a huge following
on twitter and
and and it's like wow you have this
power in the media
that traditionally you would have never
had in the old days
and and that democratization of
information is
a genius thing because now the media has
moved into
garbage land and people rely on us for
information now instead of the media and
so
it's an interesting shift what's
happened in reliability of information
you know and so we've become more and
more popular because
we're the source and so the media uses
us for our source daily but
but same with individuals they can go
directly to us
yeah it's very smart um you started out
with i think kind of early on
tens of millions of dollars in assets i
think i saw somewhere online 50 million
and it brought over a billion dollars in
assets so
uh just you know kind of objectively
it's working and
and have grown uh talk a little bit
about
how the clientele that you guys service
um
how that's evolved over the over the
years as you've gotten bigger and then
also um we can then dig into a little
bit to the strategy of kind of this
index
plus alpha yeah yeah um
so the client base is basically the same
because our
our firm is built around helping people
build wealth and then helping people
manage wealth
but we do not actually focus on ultra
high net worth so every other firm
so this was also an innovation right so
if one percent of people have a million
dollars
and a hundred percent of brokers want
those one percent of people
then you're in a really competitive
business but if they completely ignore
everybody else okay
then there's no competition for the
other 99 now what we found in society is
about 50 percent of people save and
invest money
about 50 percent of people spend all
their money and go into debt and there's
actually very little correlation to
income you know a lot of people have
this assumption that poor people can't
save or people don't make a lot of
income can't save
this there's no correlation we have a
lot of clients that don't make a lot of
income and they save their investor
money we have clients that make
not clients we have prospects that make
a million dollars that don't save
anything
you know especially out here in la so i
mean it's easy to spend a million
dollars in la
on education alone um so our client base
was really focused around the millennial
the upperly mobile um we kind of served
the client a lot of clients of the
stocks we own even
you know snapchat is next door
activision's next door so we're in santa
monica california
so our business model is focused around
younger people that have good careers
invest getting them when they're young
investing their money helping them build
wealth
but then these companies like over time
see
we're long-term thinkers like when i
started gk i wasn't like oh i'm going to
get rich quick i'm going to be a
billionaire tomorrow that was not the
goal
the goal was in 10 years like where we
are today to get to a billion dollars
and blah blah blah
we knew it was a 10-year goal because so
many of our clients didn't have much
money at the beginning
but now it's like amazing because they
went from 25 and 30 year olds
working at you know yahoo's
um but yahoo was down the street it used
to be and and now they've
moved to being an executive at snapchat
with options and all this kind of stuff
i can't tell you how many questions we
get about options and things like that
so we serve a lot of these tech
companies and it's been
it's amazing how many young people are
actually doing very well
and then we serve baby boomers so a lot
of people
know that the wire houses are scams and
now they i can't
there's no confusion anymore you know so
when you
are a client at merrill lynch or ubs
you're being sold products and
and clients understand that now and they
started to understand the difference
between a fiduciary and a broker
and the performance of the brokers have
been horrendous i mean the products are
garbage
the results have been garbage we we see
these
statements we take them over every week
and
it's garbage like if you're at ubs or
merrill lynch you could be doing
way better but the brokers don't try you
know they just don't even try
i mean it's just joke how they make
decisions of what stocks to buy and sell
so those people have now been coming to
us in droves because they're saying look
i want somebody who's really going to
manage my money not just
charge me two fees advisory fee money
management fee
put it in a bunch of you know products
basically
and go play golf and when your advisor
is a better golfer than the client
that is a warning sign it's just a
warning sign
like i could be a great golfer like i'm
good at golf but i play like
rarely because i'm busy you know and i
have a family
um and it sucks you know i lose games i
should win
but i but i work too much so so if your
advisor is wearing a golf shirt
and like showing up to the conference
and shorts you know
come on i love it i absolutely love it
um we go to these conferences and half
the guys are wearing like golf
outfits oh yeah yeah of course um you
have been all over tech stocks and in
terms of what you like what you don't
like
uh one that you have probably uh been
more outspoken than others is
tesla talk to us a little bit about kind
of your relationship
with tesla in terms of when did you
first get interested
kind of what's the thesis there and then
kind of how do you evaluate where it is
today
tesla the love story muddy waters was
mad at me because i
i said that i was going to hold tesla
forever and they're like you can't marry
a stock my
my dad taught me never marry a stock i
go i married apple a long time ago babe
i live in a nice house i think steve
jobs and tim cook and i'm not selling my
stock
and i'm not even happy with apple so um
tesla it was never meant to be this way
you know
it was just a stock you know so ipo'd
um i think eight ten years ago and when
an ipo you know they were
based in santa monica the the first
tesla thing so
you know once again when you're in
southern california and you're connected
in the
tech community you have access to
information that people in new york just
don't have
it's just it's just you see what's
happening around you talk to your
friends and
new york you guys have different sets of
information that you have an advantage
on you know
um and there's a lot of good stuff in
new york too um
and i have lots of sources in new york
too but um but la is about tech and it's
about social media that's what we're
good at in entertainment
and that's what i'm good at and so i
have an edge in these industries and
markets i grew up i have friends in all
the companies
i know the ceos cfos whatever
and and everybody talks and so on so
tesla came out
um with this great little roadster car
it was a kind of a piece of crap and i
never owned it and
and we watched it and i i always i never
really thought much of electric cars i
always like cars
um but when they ipo'd i think at ipo to
17 bucks
um they had no product and i said we're
not going to buy it until they have a
product
so everyone's like oh it's so innovative
blah blah blah i go listen
you know it's kind of like nicola until
they have a product that they can sell
something
how far can the stock go so i waited two
years watching tesla
and then the model s came out and when
the model s came out
my partner i went down to tesla and
looked at it and drove it and
and i'm a car guy i love cars i'm not a
technical car guy but i like driving i
like driving fast
i like race cars you know i i just like
cars i don't know and and and i like ice
cars actually you know it's it's not
like i'm like oh
you know i only like evs no i mean [ __ ]
i love the land i love mclarens
you know um and i've been you know
trying not to buy an expensive
car again because people give me [ __ ]
and i've been driving this tesla model 3
which i like
um but i want the roadster so
so we so i looked at the car and i said
look if this car is this good
and they can make these and it's
electric like
there's no way they lose and at the time
mercedes was actually the biggest
investor in tesla
and i had talked to some mercedes people
and they were like look we're going to
buy
tesla and i was like that would make
sense right
and so you know i figured tesla would
get to a point in their technology and a
big oem would buy them
and a story like why would you not do
that and tesla had bad financials and
they were borrowing money from the
government
so you know i was like so i
so my mom and dad my stepfather is a
very connected person in
the government and in education and they
were doing some work with spacex and
nasa and they
had dinner with elon and my mom came
back and said you got to pay attention
to this guy
he's a genius and you know i don't say
this much but
this guy is off the charts so between
that and the in the positive
you know review of elon's abilities
and my mom's not wrong um you know i was
like let's buy the stock so we bought
this talk and we kind of piled into it
you know like right at
around 30 35 bucks i think it was um
and i i think it was because we were
just betting on the launch of the s
doing well and so right off the bat the
stock
rallied from like 30 and i think that
one day it went up like
it doubled or something like a day i
think it was like right after the s came
out
and idiot me of course i sold some you
know i'm like
it doubled in a day like i'm a idiot
right and i was on my way to a vacation
or something
and i think i originally had 3 500
shares so i had about a hundred thousand
dollars in tesla
and options at 30.
[ __ ] i wish i kept that you know i you
know sometimes i'm too smart for my own
good
but you know when it got to 150 i had to
sell some
and then it kind of plateaued in there
for a while um and we and and i kept
you know i kept my tests on we kept
adding to it tesla came out with the
model x it was a disaster it was one of
the worst launches i've ever seen the
wing doors didn't work i'm like elon's
[ __ ] smart but he's an idiot
and uh he want to make the best doors
ever
we got through that then he bought solar
city i didn't like that
you know it was like it's like a
love-hate relationship but like he kept
doing
awesome stuff so we just kept kept
investing and
but then when the model 3 started
as a mass-produced vehicle i was like if
they can make this car
like it will sell forever but they have
to make it
and it turned out that was not so easy
this has been a really painful stock for
me
actually no no and i'm glad i've made a
lot of money from it now because no part
of that was easy
no part of it so anybody who thinks that
this was just some sort of like
walk in the park gain it was not and
last year was even more horrendous
so it was basically this horrendous
love-hate relationship between these
amazing products this amazing inventor
who constantly screwed everything up
because he was overly ambitious
and overly aggressive oh boy
right so so what happened was
when they launched the the model 3 the
stock rallied because they sold all the
expensive cars right off the bat and
made margin remember
and that was like the end of 18. so we
actually survived 18 pretty good i
thought 19 was going to be pretty good
because they were scaling
but it didn't turn out that way scaling
wasn't that easy
so you know everybody started shorting
tesla hard
and uh and a lot of big time players and
it's not like i ignore these people you
know i'm like geez what am i missing so
whenever i think i'm missing something i
just
work harder you know i'm like i gotta
study what they're saying
and then i gotta go figure out if it's
true and then i gotta go figure out
what's really going on
so i heard a lot of what the tesla cue
people were saying and
most of it was like personal stuff like
they just didn't like elon and i
realized that was a big flaw
they actually called me you know like uh
it was like
chainos and these guys charlie and
chanus and they wanted me to go out to
dinner with them in new york
and i was like you guys are going to
knock me off i'm not that's dumb
you know and uh
but you know i thought it was
interesting they really were concerned
about my
my thesis you know so then it was like
iron horn and then
the worst was when steve eisemann from
the big short came out short tesla
and and tesla's starting at crater and i
go home to my wife and i said you know
honey i think i'm screwed
even the big short guy is betting
against me
so so you know i don't invest based off
what other people
say i invest off my own research so i
called tesla and i said listen
i want to see everything i want to i
want to meet everybody
and i want to know what i'm doing
i'm coming up to fremont and if you
can't accommodate me
i'm selling all my stock [ __ ] you you
know it's like sorry so this guy martin
who's head of ir said i'll take care of
you ross so i fly up to fremont
he meets me i bring my wife because i
want to make sure some rational
non-stock
operator watched this you know because
she doesn't care
and uh so we go to this factory me and
my wife and martin
and i didn't want just a regular tour i
literally went through every freaking
inch of it all day long
i walked the entire model 3 assembly
line in the tent
every position i looked at the car top
to bottom i looked at the machines
i talked to the random employees i you
know
and i walked out of there i go these
[ __ ] guys are wrong
this place is amazing they're gonna kill
it
they're gonna kill i've never seen a
place like this like the motivation
level the work ethic
the the vision um the the
automation i mean the factory itself was
this hybrid of amazing technology and
then like old-school manufacturing
and then i met jerome gillian and when i
met jerome gillian i realized the shorts
were screwed
because jerome gillian is the genius
behind tesla's success it's really
as much as elon is the genius with the
vision the actual person that
saved tesla was jerome so i i had this
meeting with jerome
and in five minutes i realized he was a
genius like off the charts
he was super motivated like elon he was
relentless cost cutter
a relentless efficiency driver and he
was a truck guy
um but he wasn't from the tech side he
was from the manufacturing side
so i knew if anybody was gonna say tesla
was jerome
and he's really the guy who deserves a
lot of credit
and uh he put up the tent he got model 3
up in 17 days and he's now a legend at
tesla
and now he's running this austin plan he
helped get the china plant going
he is the secret behind this but when i
saw that i was like
i'm going to keep betting on tesla so
tesla goes from 260 to
200. now i'm getting calls that i'm
an idiot you know relatives are
seeing if i'm okay you know and it was
like the big short i was like in my
office like
by myself and then and then eli started
the pedo stuff
you know and people in my firm were like
ross we're out like
[ __ ] this guy and i was like guys
he's crazy i get that but you can't
invest
with crazy people who are geniuses and
expect normalcy
but i was getting pissed so i fly back
up to tesla
martin sets up i go to autonomy day and
it's me gene munster
and uh galley and trisha uh i think her
name is
what's her name tricia something at arc
and uh
and elon's there now i'm not scared of
elon and
i don't really care whether he likes me
or not i have millions invested in this
company
and he's [ __ ] me you know so i was
gonna
talk to him i was a little scared he
might just be like
blow me off and be like screw this guy
but i was like how do i approach it
right you know
and i was pissed off about twitter so i
approached him with gene and and they
needed to raise money back then
and i was like gene we got to get him to
stop doing this you know because i love
gene munster i think he's one of the
smartest guys out there and we did apple
together for a long time
and then when i went to tesla he went to
tesla too so i was super happy
and gene is just so smart and so and he
writes everything better than me so i
just use gene stuff
um so we cornered elon and i
i i didn't let him have it but i was
like look elon you're making it real
hard for us and i'm i can only do so
much to help you in the media and this
and that
but you tweeting all this garbage i'm
like listen i'm big on twitter too and
i've
gotten hammered for really dumb [ __ ]
i've said you know especially attacking
trump and stuff and
you've got to understand like what's the
purpose of this didn't you say
the mission is to you know sustainable
transport well you're hurting the
mission
you know like if this is the mission
this
twitter [ __ ] isn't the mission you know
and you need to raise money because you
have 2 billion left
and if anything goes wrong you're going
to run out of money and i'm telling you
they're not going to give you money
if you have to get get it you know what
i mean
next day he keeps tweeting next day
they raise money they do the second they
do that uh
convertible uh deal and i was like the
[ __ ] guy's a genius
he knew the whole time when we were
grilling him he was gonna raise money
the next day you know
and uh and so we bought that convertible
it was like two percent
convertible converted at 300 a share
so i got two percent so we bought the
hell out of that thing i got a lot of
these bonds because i i figured you know
at least i'd get the gigafactory if he
went bankrupt you know
and um and we figured the gigafactory
was worth 10 billion
and uh um and and so we we
loaded up a tesla unfortunately in the
you know under 300 range and
and and if you would have told me a year
ago that it'd be at 1 500 i would have
been like there's zero chance you know
um and it's i don't think it's worth
1500. um
nor do i care um but i think tesla now
from what i'm seeing
is about to break through into just a
whole new level of
of success you know um in
in especially full self driving um so
i'm a super bowl still on tesla
i'm a seller here i'm not a buyer i i've
taken profits
i i have to it's just prudent money
management
especially for older clients that we
have who had bigger positions in tesla
because they had more money for our
young clients we're keeping it because
they have long-term time horizons
um but like for myself you know i had a
ton of it it's like you know i can't
have
thirty percent of my net worth and stock
you know i just don't do that you know
i sleep at night you know i i'm not a
billionaire i'm not trying to be a
billionaire
i don't care you know i'm fine
is that how big the tesla position got
for you was 30
i mean it's still like 20 you know
i i mean it wasn't meant to be
that way i had options and and
i had you know i had the debt i had the
equity and i had options
so you know it's yeah it's gotten real
big and
and and you know now it's so volatile i
just don't like
i've made money there so you know i have
to take profits i i
i see i believe your only profit is what
you report on your tax return
unlike trump right so like for me if i'm
reporting losses that means i lost money
so i'm okay paying taxes on gains
if i make money you know but like i also
try not to have more than 10 of my net
worth in any one position that's kind of
like i try
to do that and uh and so that's what i'm
trying to
continue to do and so talk to me a
little bit when you say 1500 as a
position and again
you know to be super super quickly this
is not financial advice go to your
right right please don't more
traditional please be a financial
advisor
yes um but in terms of just talk through
from the
process you guys have run and the
research you've done um
you know the 1500 uh stock price
being too high is that something where
you're just saying hey look we think
it's gonna come back down and then
over a long period of time it'll
continue to appreciate it doesn't sound
like you're arguing like the tesla story
is over or
no no the tesla story isn't over at all
in fact the tesla story's just begun
um really um what it is for me
is i still believe a company is actually
a company
i run one so when i open my wells fargo
account
for example like there's cash that comes
in and cash that goes out
and that is a real thing so when we look
at a company
like i pretend like i'm buying the whole
thing
and it's like is this a good business
like i'm still a businessman
i'm more a businessman in a lot of ways
i'm not really a
i'm a stock trader because i'm sort of
born to be that
but like but i'm a businessman so like
when i buy
like that's why we sold zoom and and
docusign too
and and slack which i like all the
businesses
but at 500 times earnings i'd be like
it's like somebody coming to
to gk right now and offering me let's
say 150 million for my firm
you know it's way more than what it's
worth and and i would have to take it
you know like
it's just you know that's economics i
guess you could say you know and so like
you have to sell if somebody's gonna
give you a ridiculous premium for your
company
you know so maybe you don't sell all of
it but like
but that's just like smart right so
so if you owned a house and it was and
you paid a million dollars and madonna
knocks on your door and says i'll give
you 6 million for it
you know like i love the house and my
wife would be furious
but i would be like honey we're moving
okay like
we'll get over this fight but we'll have
five million extra dollars you know
um so with tesla the
way i value tesla is based off revenue
even though they're reporting a profit
like
they're not trying to make a profit and
i think that's a mistake i made and
missed
a lot of amazon's gain personally was
because
i i invested in amazon late i would say
and so i've made a lot of money on
amazon
um but i missed amazon like and part of
it was i was like when are they gonna
make money when are they gonna make
money they never make money
now you know what kind of firm has a
zero percent profit margin blah blah
and i didn't get vases vision you know
and i didn't like
selling crap like i was just like they
sell crap he makes no margin
i didn't see it okay but there was a
point to that because he was in like
hyper growth he was building like a way
bigger company and that's exactly what
elon is doing he's building a way bigger
company than it is today
with that vision already five years out
he's building giga factories everywhere
he's offering volkswagen batteries he
doesn't even have you know
i'm like when are you gonna get an extra
battery elon you just said on the call
you don't have enough batteries
you know um and so so so i was going to
make that mistake with tesla
and if you remember uh amazon was
overpriced for most of its history
and same with apple and same with nvidia
actually i
i think a few of the best stocks i've
ever bought were extremely expensive
when i bought them
and people thought it was a bad idea at
my firm and i did two
but i also didn't want to be out and
they've turned into like shopify i was
laid in shopify and i made a fortune and
i
i kicked myself daily i didn't buy more
because i knew how good they were but it
was too expensive
i mean that was a hundred dollars a
share it's a thousand dollars
and it's still too expensive so i sold
more
you know um so tesla you know maybe they
do 35 billion
i used to do it at three times rev i
thought three times rev for them was was
generous you know
i'm now up to five times rep just so i
don't seem like a
bear you know um so that gets you to
like what 170 billion
thousand dollars a share i think jonas
just put out a thousand dollars a share
because jonas
put out ten dollars a year ago um
so anything i'll buy tesla under a
thousand yeah i know jonas ten dollars a
year ago
two thousand today um buy high
five with morgan stanley i like jonas he
he he tries so hard he's just wrong
constantly
um he's like now we figured how tesla
actually is really good at autonomy
um i'm like dude i was in my car on pch
trying for
like the the autopilot on pch which i
think is the most challenging drive you
could possibly want
during summer people run you know it did
pretty good yesterday it's got
visualization now
boy in a year don't count this out
um so so people are paying premiums for
baseball cards as you mentioned
and people are paying for um ridiculous
speculation and penny stocks they're
buying kodak today
i mean think about how dumb that is like
kodak is going to make some sort of drug
like why doesn't jcpenney get into the
vaccine business too
you know 2020 they may we may see
jcpenney start a farmer
i would do that right now i would just
shut whatever they were doing and say
we're going to make masks and vaccines
the government will give me 500 million
stock rallies
you know you got portnoy or somebody
will will pump it and you and you're
good to go
i love dave the penny stock operators
are like so happy
it's like it's never been so good for
them so you obviously you know who the
short sellers
are or were uh you spent time with them
you've heard their arguments
what do you think is the thing that they
missed on tesla
so here's here's one of my theories
that many people on wall street don't
like
so i do think valuations matter they
matter a ton
but they also don't matter okay
perception of success or future success
of a company can create ridiculous
valuations so
a lot of people bet against companies
purely based on valuation
and i think that's a bad idea it's just
a bad idea
you know i can tell you 100 stocks i
think are overvalued i don't bet against
them
i just don't bet against stuff very
often because the market's rigged to go
up and if you don't
you know i think dave says that too
stocks always go up
they don't always go up i wish that was
true
but it is rigged to go up theoretically
so so in my mind where the short sellers
were wrong on tesla i think
mostly they weren't wrong the financials
were garbage
they were losing money like crazy they
had elon had invested so aggressively
he literally put no margin for error in
fact
the short sellers had a very good
argument
a very very good argument and and not
only did they have
everything in their favor then elon was
even helping them
okay with pedo and in the sec
you know the other day he posted
something that you know suck
whatever and i was like dangerous you
know and uh he was like yes
and i'm like elon please so i email you
know ir and i'm like
take his phone run run dive in front of
his phone you know like i tell martin
no really there's a lot of behind the
scenes you know
like i'm like run to his office dive in
front of his fingers you know
like stop him you can always tell what
kind of mood elon's in if you really
follow his tweets you know
and if he's tweeting a lot before
earnings be careful
he's happy so
that was pretty obvious he was going to
blow out numbers this time um so i don't
think the short sellers were wrong
i'll tell you where they were wrong as
they didn't go to the factory they
didn't see where elon slept
on the floor they didn't see the people
that were working there who will die
working there they care so much they
did not see the work ethic like i came
back from a factory
super motivated i was like i'm weak i'm
i am soft
no seriously and i push you know like
but we have millennials here you know
god if i no trust me like the way i
would be doing things
the way i used to they would all quit
they would all quit
you know now we have like snack bars and
stuff you know we have like
like quiet time we have like sing-alongs
we have to we have to you know the
millennials need it
but they're doing great they're doing
great i have had to adjust i've had to
adapt
i'm gen x and i come from the bang the
phones close the business
generation you know um but now it's
the biggest thing that you've had to do
that you could have never imagined you
would have to do
having millennials work there like
what's that every day
i'm not yell at people how about that i
mean
people cry like you know if you
like so so my my i think one of my
greatest qualities and one of my biggest
flaws
are the same things so i see the best in
people like i see what i
you know i i i train people like i
manage people and i love people
and i see the best in people but i also
see something a lot of times they don't
see
you know and and so then it's like i
push them to be what they can be
but that process is painful for some
people it's kind of like the military
you know like
i trained a little bit like the military
i studied the military extensively my
dad's been in the military his whole
life and
um on and off and and my grandfather and
and and i study military history and i
and and i very much
studied like the marines like how do the
marines train somebody you know
and i train a lot of young people so i
and and repetition and all these kind of
things are really important
but but they toughen you up you know
they toughen you up and
and and so that process is a little bit
different now you know
the toughening up process uh is a little
kinder a little gentler
um but we do have a very much a training
program to
take the socialist millennials that we
get and turn them into fierce
capitalists
and we do this over time um so we really
have a very
we might write a book about this you
know like i've been i started
a millennial management book and i and i
stopped because
i just didn't have time but you know
but we have ridiculous things we do here
to keep people motivated
and they totally work what's the
craziest thing
what we're doing right now every year we
have the gk cup
and the gk cup is was based off the
world cup so one year the world cup was
happening and nobody [ __ ]
works during the world cup and it's
super frustrating because i have a lot
of immigrants here
so there is nothing soccer or soccer
so i was like how do i get these people
to work during the world cup i'll create
my own world cup
so i bought this enormous cup you know
like a
huge award like the stanley cup and we
engrave
their names in the cup if they win the
contest it's a summer contest
so in summer it's so hard to get people
to work in la it's like perfect out
right now
so we had a contest and they go
head-to-head like they have the groups
and they go head-to-head we set all
these random criterias
you know a performance related thing
metrics
and then they compete all summer long to
win
really just getting their name on the
cup but they care so much
about getting their name on the cup now
the best part is if there's a tie
we do real penalty kicks with a real
ball
and a real goal okay now
please i can't tell you now we're doing
this socially distant with masks on now
but i cannot tell you how much fun this
is it is so much fun
and and and women in our firm went
like there's there was this sort of
complaint like oh well the women aren't
as good as soccer i go that's ridiculous
and that's sexist
and then they go and they beat the guys
in the kickoffs and and so we have
you know women are more i think we have
more women winners of the cup
at our firm than men even though we have
you know kicking
the soccer ball um but it's super fun
and everybody gets into it and our
production just goes through the roof
like if i just said i'm gonna give a
thousand dollars to the guy who's the
best you know they just
they don't care they don't care about
money
speaking of money uh bitcoin you were
converted a while ago by brock pierce
yeah and roger vere kind of what your uh
what has your journey been with bitcoin
kind of what are your thoughts now
i love bitcoin you know
so bitcoin's really disappointing to me
right now because i feel like the
developers who are very very smart
who promised a lot of things to people
have not done their jobs i think they
made too much money
and they just were like this it's easier
just to print the money
and make the money than to actually make
it useful like they promised
and that's my gripe right now so there's
two gripes i have with bitcoin because
i've been hacked and attacked
for my bitcoin before and it's a
nightmare i had a 2f8
attack by the way lock your sim card
everybody boy nightmare if they get your
phone
and they can get your phone easily um so
locker sim card um
but like first of all exchanges offer no
protection
so coinbase major firm how am i going to
put a million dollars in bitcoin
when it can just disappear and i have no
protection the exchanges certainly don't
help you
you can't recover anything there's no
sipc
so i've been arguing for a long time
bitcoin needs an
sipc it just needs an insurance like
i would pay in a certain amount per
transaction transaction
to just know my money at coinbase and
binance and bittrex and all these places
is safe
but it's like somebody can just hack in
and take your money and there's
literally nothing you can do how is
bitcoin going to grow
into this enormous thing with
institutions investing
if you have no security so like if you
read
um there's a great book about the
winklevoss twins uh ben
mizrach who i love wrote this book
billionaire bitcoin billionaires
highly recommend it and they go through
this part about how they
secured all their bitcoin and the
process they had to go through
to make it secure and it's absurd it's
absurd
so if you're gonna have a million
dollars in bitcoin
i can't even tell you how much effort it
is just to keep that safe
where you can just give me a million
dollars nothing can happen to it so i
think the exchanges have to solve that
problem
uh insurance protection um
secondly use i i can't believe i
like if i want to buy something i can
apple pay with two clicks why can't i
just
play with bitcoin i still can't do it
i can't do it through paypal i can't do
it through anybody
i can't do it through coinbase i can't
do it through square cash
like why can't square cash can't i just
use bitcoin to pay for things
i want to use my bitcoin to pay for
things and i still can't
i still can't so i think this needs to
be solved
if these two things are solved bitcoin
goes up forever
what is your thought process in terms of
maybe not price prediction
but in terms of uh is bitcoin eventually
the next global reserve currency is it
already is
explain well like so the genius of
bitcoin
right so so the genius of bitcoin was
like gold it has a finite amount
of bitcoin and so the mine the longer
you mine the coins
we just had to having you know
the the harder it is to get more coins
so now there's half as many coins
printed per day
than there was a year ago this process
is very much like gold so what makes
gold valuable is less per se the gold
is more per se the fact it's so hard to
get new gold and the amount of gold
actually stays the same so it works real
well
if we all collect the same rock and we
just don't find new rocks
but if you actually study the history of
silver the reason why silver isn't a
reserve currency
is because they found a lot of it and
they were like this isn't that hard you
know
not worth that much then um so bitcoin
has the ability to
just like gold to go up forever because
so my my whole theory about money
actually i was going to write about this
because now the government's printing
money so fast that
i don't even believe in the dollar
anymore like i just don't even believe
in cash
anymore like so there's no value to
holding cash
because it's being printed so fast that
the
between inflation and the cost of living
and everything going up
because of this that holding dollars is
the
easiest way to lose all your money so
over a hundred years
if you had a hundred dollars you will
end up with a dollar
of of equivalent value but if i take
that hundred dollars and convert it to
bitcoin or gold
in a hundred years it will go up with
inflation
so i don't see why bitcoin acts any
differently than gold
and in fact if bitcoin was able to deal
with larger institutional investors
it would be worth fifty thousand dollars
but until i can like i have clients who
want to buy bitcoin and i say i can't do
it for you hey i can't
b like you wanna buy fifty thousand
where you know i do trades at like fifty
thousand a hundred thousand
i can't do that with bitcoin it's just
too hard
just trying to buy a hundred thousand in
bitcoin you know it's like a penny stock
well and i think part of the probably
the biggest obstacle for you is uh
just the fiduciary duty of buying
bitcoin and kind of regulations and
things like that
that's a whole other issue but yeah yeah
but the the institutional stuff now i
think is getting
a little bit better right you see people
like fidelity and and others coming in
and yeah
cameron and tyler have done a great job
with gemini uh yeah i think that
the you know the coin bases they just
bought uh tagomy which is a uh basically
a prime brokerage type business
right right i think a lot of this is
kind of coming together but to your
point
uh until it is as dead simple as
what somebody's used to doing in the
legacy world like there will be
obstacles
maybe yeah like i'm not selling my
bitcoin you know i mean i haven't been a
buyer
in a while because after the hack i was
really turned off you know it sucks
it's it's still i'm still trying to get
control of some of my accounts it's like
just security is a nightmare and but
like
right so i just don't feel comfortable
having that much money in bitcoin
because
it's like so hard to deal with it how do
you think about
uh it in your portfolio is it something
that you're like look it's like a one to
two percent type allocation
more like you know uh an inflation hedge
or something bigger like
how do you put it together exactly that
it's maybe a one to two percent of your
portfolio it's an inflation hedge
it works the same as gold it's digital
gold um in my mind
you know so i'm not a big believer in
governments
so i have some pretty radical beliefs
that i don't talk about much because
people let's talk about them right now
yeah
so one of them is i think that most
governments of the world
are the most corrupt mess of disgraceful
attempts at governing that i've ever
seen i don't think there's
ever been a time in history except maybe
in the 30s when
we had hitler stalin and you know the
whole thing in japan and you know
imperialism or whatever you want to call
it it's
really disgraceful how governments
haven't served
not only the people um but from rich to
poor
and the theft i mean just in la the
every day you read an article about
politicians who've stolen from
developers and from people
and and the corruption probes up and
down
to the president of the united states so
so i think that governments
in general have lost its utility in a
lot of ways
and and so things like bitcoin
make a lot of sense to me because why do
i have to live in a world
where the us can just i have to use
their money
when their money is worthless and they
just print it like crazy
and give it to people you know but i
could own this bitcoin
and go anywhere in the world and use it
okay
so to me bitcoin makes so much sense in
this world
it could be hugely successful if they do
this right
but i still think all the major players
that should be doing it got too rich
and they're just not trying that hard
anymore and and i think they need to try
harder
and i think it'll work and i think
there's never been a time between the
euro
the you know in the eu they're going to
issue a trillion dollars
of debt backed by the eu for the first
time
not backed by a country not backed by
any individual
not backed by anything just the eu
now we all know that the eu is a
farcical thing that everybody wants to
leave
right it's a failed experiment basically
that they're still trying to keep going
so what rate are they offering on that
trillion dollars
it's minus point one
now i went around all day saying i will
borrow
indefinite amount of money at minus
point one just give me
all the money in the world at minus
point one who's gonna give money
at minus point one uh obviously somebody
does
so this is proof that the entire system
has failed
it's failed like we failed i go on to
buy bonds right now
i'll leave this podcast i go on i say i
want a one-year bond
from apple it's a negative yield
nobody's reporting this this is not on
the news
oh every bond that's a year or less
that's not going to default
has a negative yield like i have to run
like
a really long screen to get a bond with
a yield
that's a failure of an entire system our
entire system has failed
so the entire financial system is
backwards now so what what
happens like i don't know it doesn't
work
so so in my mind none of this works so
how do we get out of it
i don't know i don't know once you have
negative yields
we've i mean i went to school you went
to school you're a really smart guy
like you you know what's gonna happen
like if you print a trillion dollars
every two months
and and and you only have to pay 0.5 on
it see i think it works
as long as the idiots give you the money
okay so so somebody's giving them the
money at negative yields it's not me
my computer won't even let me buy it
it's like reject negative yield
i was like boy at least my computers
won't let me do stupid [ __ ]
but somebody's computer is letting them
do this so
explain to me what's going to happen all
these short-term bond funds and money
market funds with negative yields and
they're still paying point one
i think marcus is paying one percent i
think betterment or
wealthfront's paying one percent so how
are they paying one percent
but they're buying bonds that yield
negative how long does that work
so how do banks work with negative
yields
so all of a sudden you start to realize
that we've created
a nightmare a financial nightmare box
that i can't
figure out our way out of now we have 20
of america unemployed
i drive down the streets to empty
buildings so next door is activision
empty snapchat empty my building
empty except for us we're like why
aren't people working in their offices
what's wrong you know like you wear a
mask and you go to work you know it's
like
we have people farther apart we have a
big office fortunately and not everybody
comes in
all the time but you know nobody coming
in
just so what happens to real estate
what's going to happen all this debt
who's paying i wouldn't be paying my
rent
for a office building i'm not using who
owns that activision building
you know as an activist shareholder i'm
not stoked that they're paying rent on a
building they're not using
who owns all this debt where does this
all go
so i have 50 of my money in cash what
would you
put the probability at right now that
the existing system
actually fails in the united states and
it has to be replaced by another one
is that like a one percent possibility i
think the problem is what's the other
one
um
so remember in the financial crisis
there's this moral hazard thing
like if we bail everybody out there was
a long discussion about it
see i always say this in my office and
to my wife
you know i don't like aging very much
i'm not a fan of it
and the only advantage is experience
you know that's the only edge i have
over these kids you know
and i work out real hard just to stay as
fast and strong as them but
but boy you know experience is really
valuable so moral hazard
was a really debated
issue with bernanke and geithner and
and obama at the time like if we bail
out all these banks and just give them
money
what's going to happen the next time and
and i have to say dodd-frank has worked
so
so to the upside dodd-frank has worked
and so because of that we don't have a
banking crisis right now
that's huge because if we had a banking
crisis right now
what you're saying i think would be
probably 50 chance our system wouldn't
make it
so if we were if the banks oh yeah for
sure i mean
the banks control there's five bank four
banks control the entire
they're too big to fail like we didn't
solve any of that
they're bigger so if jp morgan goes down
like what happens right like america
shuts down
basically so fortunately dodd-frank has
worked so i think that prevents
a worse thing secondly i'm a big
believer in innovation and technology
remember
a lot of innovations happening right now
a lot of things a lot of companies are
adapting a lot of companies are doing
well
i'm shocked that's what's confusing to
me
like i i go to one place and they're
like out of business and then you go to
the next place
like like the nursery you know like is
packed everybody's buying plants you
know
uh home depot doing amazing you know but
then the restaurants is just like
it's like it is it's like a holocaust
for restaurants right now and
and it's sad it it's it's just a sad
death
that there's no way around you know um
so unemployment i think is going to stay
high for a long time
and we're going to have social unrest
for a long time we're going to have
social cost
to this suicides drug abuse crime um
i don't think the they call it a
recession i don't think the recession's
really started yet
it started but like the pain hasn't
started
because they just keep printing money
and and there's been no
no issue but now the 600 ends on friday
and
it's gonna suck so i keep calling like
bridge the gap stimulus which the whole
idea was
hey there's going to be this market
downturn mainly because we have to shut
down the economy so let's just print
some money
give us a shot in the arm and by the
time this program runs out at the end of
july or the end of september depending
on the program
like the economy will have recovered and
no one will be any worse
off you know when we kind of bridge the
gap the problem is that like
we didn't build a long enough bridge
right because right
like like oh [ __ ] we're halfway through
building the bridge no it's not that we
didn't build a long enough
bridge we underestimated our stupidity
so so in fact one
you know i god i hate this i've spent
more time studying this [ __ ] disease
you know and i have some clients who are
virologists and some of the top people
in these areas who are very smart so
i i've forced myself to listen to this
and read all this stuff
coronavirus isn't complicated we've made
it way worse than it needs to be
it's an airborne disease you know it's
easily stopped
if you know it's an airborne disease so
you have to take
you know the appropriate you know things
because it's so contagious
you know the real challenge of
coronavirus is a lot of people don't get
sick
so they're not sick and and they're
contagious and you know it's just real
hard to stop something you can't find
or see so the simple solution is what
they're doing at the nba
and what we've done at my firm is you
you create a bubble and you test
everybody
in and and then you hopefully people
don't act stupid
okay don't act stupid
so where i am in la santa monica people
are germaphobic
super healthy people yell at each other
if you're not wearing masks
okay like somebody yell at my wife she
was jogging you know like
where's your mask and my wife's like
what the [ __ ] you know i'm jogging
you know my wife pulled a cairn on a
white guy the other day it was pretty
funny
and uh yeah
yeah i mean this guy's like hassling her
uh my wife is gonna deal with that
so um and she runs a lot um
but then we went to orange county so we
go down to orange county we go to laguna
beach her family's from laguna beach and
we go to the beach down there because
it's like hawaii it's so nice
and um and i and i walk down there and
there's like
150 people partying hanging out the kids
are playing the
families are all eating and drinking
together and we go over to our little
corner or our beach
and i go jill holy [ __ ] we're
[ __ ] we are screwed do these people
know that there's a pandemic
see a lot of people don't know what a
pandemic is
they don't understand that pandemics
don't care about what they think
um somebody said this that you know you
might not care about the virus but the
virus still cares about you
and uh and that's what we're seeing
right now in orange county just
explosion of cases
we've had a governor and our mayor who's
allowed construction
and essential workers the latino
community is completely sick with this
thing
because they've allowed these people to
work during the quarantine so that their
developer friends and
and their big business friends wouldn't
lose money but now they've infected the
entire latino community here in los
angeles
and that's who really is getting it look
at florida california
arizona uh texas you think this is just
a coincidence so you have this stupid
behaviors and then you have this latino
community
that's been working this whole time that
have basically just been sacrificed
by our business leaders with no
protective gear and no
safety protocols at i mean there's a
downtown factory i had 400 cases
and four people die and nobody said
anything and i'm just like
what the hell what the hell is going on
and then in mexico
the president of mexico was like uh we
don't even believe in coronavirus
and it's a nightmare in mexico right now
and the mexican community
goes back and forth a lot between mexico
and the united states
they're very close-knit families um
they're very dense communities
and this is a nightmare it's a nightmare
so
um this is not going away anytime soon
and that's the premise we're working on
now and so
you know i tend to think that the data
is suggesting that
um i i asked a bunch of people for
questions i'm gonna fire them at you
rapid fire
uh hear your thoughts uh let's start
with day trading versus holding
and the recent rise of the day traders
well i've been around long enough these
day traders if they were so good they'd
all be rich right
so 99 to one one percent of people have
a million dollars 99 percent down
they day traded in in the 90s they
flipped houses in the 2000s
they are back to day trading again
it just oh it was bitcoin remember the
bitcoin stuff my uber driver trading
ethereum from his car
i mean so
it's sad to me the get rich quick
american ideology that people buy into
whether it's betting on sports or
day trading or there's no get rich quick
man
you know i i wish i
you know i wish i could tell you you
know like it's luck like there are some
people who are very lucky
and and it's just not something that's
repeatable so you save and invest your
money over the long term you'll you'll
be a millionaire for sure
for sure over 20 to 30 years if you
invest in the s p even
um so that's discipline it's not as fun
so my whole thing is if i buy a business
how much money can that business make me
in one day
i buy mcdonald's did something happen at
mcdonald's yesterday that was so good
that it deserves to be 10
higher you know it's like so when you
own a business like whether it's tesla
or mcdonald's or apple you have earnings
per share
those are real dollars that flow into it
and then those ceos have to make a
decision whether to buy back stock or
pay dividends or
buy a business or grow i believe in all
that
so if i'm buying a business to hopefully
sell that business
later in the day for profit um i think
that's a stupid thing to do
mostly because the best day trades i've
made
really are over a couple weeks you know
like to really get a stock ramping so if
you're just like buying and selling
so i learned this lesson when i was 28
it was 1999 and i was lucky enough to
spend the day on the floor of the new
york stock exchange
i got to go with a floor brokers this
irish guy and they set me up with this
guy i was a kid
it was the coolest thing ever it was the
top of the market back before digital
had taken over
yelling the phones wall street the movie
i was finally there i was stoked you
know like as a kid i was like this is
cool you know so i'm on the floor now
the exchange all
guys irish guys italian new york guys
toughest guys you'll meet best traders
in the world
guy look now i'm this kid wide-eyed like
wow
so moral of the story is he says you see
everybody here
we're all millionaires every single one
here
you know why because we trade every day
and we
have better information we're on the
floor of the exchange
i said that's a good point then he
showed me this guy and he was typing
like this
he was typing trades in like this
because this was they still had
computers then
obviously but it was like only the
market specialists
had these computers and they were
filling the small orders
and the and the guys on the outside were
yelling for the 10 000 shares and above
so this guy's typing like this and i go
what's he doing he goes oh he's filling
all the smallers i go i've never seen a
guy type like
so fast you know i was like crazy and he
was basically
look the business mistake you can make
is trade against us we're the
specialists on the floor of the exchange
we have better information
we're faster we're quicker and we do
this for a living don't trade against us
and i was like i was done day trading i
was done j train
and so what i realized is that why would
i trade against virtue
why would i trade against you know uh
ken griffin and citadel
you're trading against people with
better information faster computers
you know so so why do you think you're
going to win when 99
of people don't you're not you're not
the special one so i don't believe in
that what i do believe in
if you want to speculate in a stock and
you want to buy an option and you know
try to
speculate in stock fine but accept what
it is
if you take a small portion of your
money you want to bet on stuff
fine but it's not investing
you know some of my clients they just
keep their little 50 000 account and
they want to bet on stuff
and then they they go and then they own
all the same stocks i own and i go why
didn't
you're just buying the stuff i'm
tweeting about anyways like you know
really um so i
i just think people should understand
that
why are you competing it's like playing
football against
you know like i was going to say the the
patriots but it's really you know the
tampa bay now i guess right
so so why play football against the
patriots and bill belichick you know
it's just
why not just be on their team and you
can buy mutual funds or etfs
where you're on their team you can
invest with professionals
that will help you even if you want to
buy a stalker at least have some
help you know but the real money trading
is made
by owning positions over you know some
period of time maybe
even a few months or a few weeks so you
can really get that gain you know
but today i buy a stock and hopefully
you sell it by the end of the day
you're wasting a lot of time you're
paying a lot of taxes and you're giving
you know
i think ken griffith's new apartment in
new york i think it costs 240 million
and he's divorced so he paid a divorce
and still has money and he runs the
biggest market maker in the world
think about it you uh
you've gotten in multiple uh online
conversations we'll call them with uh
with dave portnoy oh yeah dave that's
from barstool uh
what's kind of the idea there i think i
saw you today tweet and say he's got a
nice comedy show
it is a comedy show that's not serious
right
no i mean look dave's a smart guy right
he he built bar bar stool it's a
you know he's a marketing guy i i i use
some of the same
techniques that dave uses i don't
dislike him i i actually think he's kind
of funny
um and you know why he thinks i'm a suit
whatever you know uh you know i'm
actually the anti-wall street guy so i
kind of found that funny
because he's just you know he's a ranter
but um
you know i like guys like dave you know
dave helps us
a lot because the people who listen to
dave lose their money and then they call
financial advisors
when they realize they can't do it um so
they these people help
us you know um and and they popularize
investing and since investing is so hard
you know this investing is so hard
um and it's so humbling you know if you
do it for any
you know look i'm i'm on a roll right
now so i'm feeling pretty good
but trust me i've lost money you know
like
it's humbling dude it's it's brutal it's
just brutal it's a brutal job
i actually don't recommend this to
people at all
i think trading's really hard and uh and
now i'm responsible for a billion
dollars
and and if i'm wrong i might lose
millions
now that i take that responsibility
seriously so so
so my thing with dave portney portnoy is
uh
um number one i think he's funny i do
um number two um
he he clearly discloses that he's not
serious it says it like
don't follow what i'm saying it's a
comedy show it is
and and so i think it's it's it's funny
now i don't watch it very often just
because
you know it's like watching a train
wreck and we're all waiting for him to
lose all his money
you know because it'll be funny when he
does and i hope he quits
soon you know like i think he's smart so
what he's going to do is he's going to
quit while he's ahead
declare victory and go back to sports
because sports is starting back up
um and so you know with the nba starting
tomorrow
he he actually has a a tough job because
he's working for penn
and penn is very leveraged right now
with a lot of casinos and if corona gets
bad
and and penn has to shut their casinos
again you know
boy they don't own their casinos they
rent them
and and then secondly bar stool is an ad
rev business and adrev is down huge
so they're getting hurt right now and
there's no sports
and their app isn't even out yet so you
know dave's got a lot of work to do
you know i like his life isn't so easy
i i i you know so i like it i i
i love see what what twitter does
is it creates engagement and
there's good engagement there's bad
engagement someone could say it's bad
engagement he's talking [ __ ] about you
and i was pretty annoyed the first time
and i and my friends were like you
should just [ __ ] hammer this guy and
i go i'm not
i'm not going there you know what i mean
like it's like i'm not
on that level you know i mean i i manage
money for real and
and i and i don't have time to start you
know playing games with this guy
uh but i enjoy it i honestly i do
or are you a buyer of penn stock no
i'm an owner of mgm so i'm a competitor
um
i we have a big position in mgm that
we're building
i do believe in online gambling i think
mgm's in a better position i think it's
a better company it's trading at below
book value
i've known these companies since i was a
kid i've been an investor in mirage and
mgm
back in the day so i know vegas really
well
really really well and i know what a
piece of [ __ ] pen is you know
so penn penn owns like the worst casinos
you can imagine they literally serve
the lowest income economic group and so
i just don't see that as a great
business you know like
especially with a recession and and all
these problems and
and and every casino they had is in a
coronavirus hotspot right now
um and i don't think barstool has an
edge on
on sports betting i think draftkings
does i like
draftkings actually and i like paddy
power which
is really owns fanduel and so
we love online gambling and it's going
to be a setback for gambling because i'm
actually
bearish on sports until next year or
like mid
next year so i actually because i'm in
the music industry
so you know we're [ __ ]
in the music industry and i deal with
golden voice
you know through one of my companies and
and and we produce
music and it's so grim dude it's so grim
so live events casinos
um sports
it's not looking good the uh
uh two more questions for you and then
we'll do uh the final let's wrap
up uh the tech anti-trust hearings
well of course they're monopolies i mean
if we cared about monopolies we would
have done something a long time ago
goal in america is to build a monopoly
microsoft taught everybody that
and uh i think
there's two things one do they abuse
their position of power of course
of course if you were amazon why
wouldn't you run your products in front
of others
it's your your website um
is it anti-competitive of course of
course it is
i mean if i'm trying to start an app and
i have to put it on the app store
it's cost me 30 i have no negotiating
power at all
and if i'm not on apple i can't sell
anything so a lot of companies are now
just trying to get people to sign up
on the website and then they can have
the app and so on and so forth i
that's what we're doing with my music
company so we're doing live shows and
like if we build an app they're going to
take 30 of my
my ticket price and we can barely
[ __ ] survive like i can't run live
live streams of music with 30 going to
apple so the way we're doing is you have
to sign up on on your phone on your web
and then you get a code and you just put
it into the app
but it sucks 30 is outrageous
so the issue going back to what i was
saying before i don't believe the
politicians care at all
i think it's just trump trying to beat
up his enemies before the election
i think that they have no power they're
not smart enough
their lawyers can't beat the the private
sector lawyers
any attempt to hurt these companies will
only hurt america
it'll hurt jobs it'll hurt us in
competition against the chinese
like where's the win
so so all these guys care about is the
election and what's going to happen
trump wants to beat up on these guys so
they don't uh put
so many bad articles about them that's
all he cares about
the uh the most asked question i don't
know what you could say where you can is
about the ppp
yeah what uh just rants
away in terms of i saw nine million
different tweets about it i know you
know
people are really concerned about like
trying to run a business
during a pandemic and you know i did
you know i did say the ppp was a scam
but that was taken out of contact see
what happened was
when the pvp went down the market was
down 35
and it was like a [ __ ] nightmare you
know
now i'm used to these nightmares because
i'm old enough
so i go into battle mode you know
so i actually performed decently under
nightmares because i've had to deal with
many of them
not because i like it so
you know nightmare happens we're getting
you know we have 7000 clients
markets down we get paid 100 based off
how much assets we have
100 of our income and we're a growing
company so i had hired
you know obviously based off having a
great year and we're expanding and
growing and i had all these staff
members that
you know it's like we're growing and we
do events
and marketing and all these divisions we
have right
so when all this went down um we applied
for the loan
because we just like we don't have
private equity it's not like i got five
million dollars sitting here
you know i i wish that would be great
um so i didn't want to have to fire
anybody and what happened was when we
applied we got
you know the first round just like came
and went and i was like this [ __ ]
sucks
and then like the lakers got it and like
like the catholic church got a billion
and a half and i was like this is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and there were three percent commissions
to the banks
which still nobody's talking about so
the bank made it through
so they were pushing us to get the loan
so like they sent me this thing and i
was like i'm going to apply
everybody's applying and if my rev goes
down 20 or 30
i'm gonna have to fire people for sure
for sure now look i did financial crisis
i fired
i think it was 50 to 60 people i had to
shut five offices i had 15 offices i
shot a third of the co i basically shot
a third of the company
right off the bat and that helped save
us
i'm not you know unfortunately i'm a
business person so i will do what i have
to do to survive
and um and you know but everybody who
works here is kind of like my family you
know
it's it's it's brutal so so we got the
mon so the second round came and we got
the money
um and i'm really grateful for it to be
honest um we kept everybody on staff and
and and certainly at the time i had no
idea that we'd be making money right now
boy i didn't think that all in fact
we were thinking the market should be
down like 40 or 50 you know
because with the financial crisis we
were down 50 so i figured we'll go down
50 this time
you know and i still think we could go
down 50. so by no means do i think i'm
out of the woods
i'm still in combat mode we have a
little bit of a cushion now thanks to
ppp
the market's come back so our revenues
come back and we've
actually used it to hire more people so
you know
what we're trying to do is is help out
by
by adding people so a lot of people in
financial services have been laid off
and we've been able to get some really
good people recently
so you know i'm stretched again and
taking risk
having so many people but we have this
cushion and we're trying to do our thing
um
i get people criticizing because the
perception is that i'm wealthy and i
shouldn't get government money
and i am wealthy um but that's not the
way business works
okay um i have a company i have
shareholders
i have employees and i'm going to have
to do what's best for my company and my
shareholders
at the expense of employees and i care
about those people
so i'm very grateful that i haven't had
to lay anybody off and now
we've used this opportunity to try to
help out by by growing
um i'm willing to take the criticism i i
get it
um you know i'm gonna do what i have to
do to survive so i'm here in 10 years
and if people don't like that then
they've never been responsible for 31
people
you know and it's like we have single
parents with kids like
i play with their kids like you try
firing a single mom
okay with a kid right now
what other job is she gonna get so
people don't think about that they can
tweet all their [ __ ] they want
okay but i go to work every day and see
these people
and their kids and their families i
don't want to fire anybody and i haven't
fired anybody so it's great
it's great so so i am grateful i do want
to say i'm grateful for
it um i haven't had to go beg some bank
for money i haven't had to
um you know sell you know we did raise
money internally too i did put money in
personally you know fairly substantial
amount of money into the company too
and and many of our employees so that we
have this cushion
um but fortunately you know revenue
hasn't gone down now so we only lost one
quarter you know where it was down and
and now we're up so you know but i i
still think the market's going to go
down 15
or more i still think we're going to be
dealing this for a year
i think anybody who thinks that it's a
fun
experience running a company right now
has no idea what we go through every day
you have no idea what i go through every
day just to keep everybody safe
irrelevant of the cost just the process
you know um but when you're responsible
you know and i have a second company too
so my music company i have six other
employees and that company's not doing
as well
um and i'm gonna have to make tough
decisions there um
so i've got 40 people who rely on me and
i take that very very seriously
and that's the answer you know and if
people don't understand that's their
right
and they can criticize me all they want
but in the end i'm going to keep my
people here and i'm going to keep my
business going and we're going to make
money
ultimately in the end and and serve our
clients and and
you know life will go on and the
government gave out money to everybody
so i'm sure they got theirs too
i feel like that's a pretty thorough
answer so anyone who's got anything
listen you know i get it i get it
criticize me all you want
you're not in my position you know but
when you look at
your team and it's a big team and you
have to decide which six or eight are
gonna go
dude it's a nightmare dude it's a
nightmare i i don't know if you've ever
had
a lot of employees or whatever you know
i care very much
for the people i work with every day
yeah i asked the same two questions to
end each podcast the first is what is
the most important book that you've ever
read
important oh
boy important has a lot of
different meanings you know do you want
to talk about finance you want to talk
about
life you know because whatever book you
want because finance books are not the
most important books that i've ever read
um books that have influenced me like
the most
number one is jack halrak jack kerouac
was my favorite writer as a child i read
every book topped a bar and read them
twice
not just on the red you know like dharma
buns you know the whole
those books changed so i was a so
it started so the beat generation
changed my life
you know like i i uh for some reason
when at that age when i was started into
that
it it opened up my whole world of like
individualism
freedom you know i'm basically a hippie
um
and then the dalai lama i would say
number two um
art of happiness is a great book
we all deal with mental issues and i
have too
when i was younger you know i had many
uh
internal debate about life and we all do
this i don't think anybody is
and i think in some ways you know my
mind
has certain complexities that are good
and padded so
i was trying to figure it out and i
found buddhism in general
and spiritual things like meditation
and it started so i met the dalai lama i
was lucky enough to meet the dalai lama
and um he said like five sentences and
they all
were amazing and it was like you could
just sit and think about this stuff for
all day and it kind of changed my life
and i
and i and now spiritualism is really
popular and people aren't as much into
religion
um but i think being able to find
a mental place in this crazy world
is the biggest challenge um and so
for me that's been an important
thing um insanity in maintaining sanity
in a crazy world
um you know and maintaining sanity and a
tough job
with lots of volatility and lots of
people
um so i highly recommend that i highly
recommend anything
dalai lama or buddhism and i highly
recommend uh
you know beat generation and
existentialism
no one has recommended either once those
great recommendations uh second one's
more
fun and then you're gonna get to ask me
one question to finish up
uh aliens believer or non-believer
i mean it depends what how you define an
alien you know i think there's a lot of
aliens on earth
i lived in venice you know so
you know when you live in venice for ten
years or whatever i did
boy you have to try to be different you
know you gotta try real hard
there's like you people talk about
diversity right
um i don't believe in
uh aliens from like another universe
um i think our solar system is kind of a
fluke like our universe is a fluke
like the sun and like the big bang and
this whole universe that we
know of and and so i kind of believe in
god
like in life is god like so
so i i don't know i think we're i think
we have a really
we overestimate our value a lot we're
just a bunch of [ __ ] animals you know
and we're all gonna die and it's ugly
and it's horrible
and we're a little bit better than
monkeys and stuff and
and we just over exaggerate our
importance okay
we're not that important we're just
little creatures who die
very easily as it turns out and a little
pandemic can throw our whole
civilization
for a loop so i think we overestimate
our value
substantially i don't think there's
other people running around
if anything they wouldn't they certainly
wouldn't show up here right
like they'd be like i'm not going to
that universe because it's all [ __ ] up
there
so you know i just don't see that man i
i love that we're all just animals we
are
we are we just we think too much we we
give ourselves a lot of credit
all right you could ask me one question
to finish up what do you got for me
uh you know i was curious you know i
started uh
obviously reading up about you a little
bit um you know what what inspires you
to do
uh these podcasts um you know i
i guess this is how you make money um
what what inspires you
to do this yeah well it all started
um we've got a whole asset management
business right so you have like an asset
management business
yep asset management business that is
private or public equities
uh all private all venture capital
private okay some crypto stuff
um and basically the whole idea was just
i had access to a lot of really smart
people
and i enjoy talking to them and learning
and i started to record the
conversations
and you're in new york right now new
york yeah
so is that where you always worked
uh no i was out in san francisco for a
while okay cool
in the new york um but i think that you
know
it's one of these weird things where
it's like probably the most selfish
thing i do is where i get to
talk to really smart people they
basically educate me on their view of
the world on a whole bunch of different
topics that i'm interested in they're
interested in
and then i record it and you know tens
of thousands of other people will listen
and they'll get to learn
alongside right well you built you build
a a really big following you know i mean
it's
it's impressive you know because i think
you know
before you know twitter and fintwit i
didn't think anybody cared about this
stuff you know it's like
when i would go that's why i love new
york i would go to new york
and hang out with my new york friends
and you know the cnbc people or whatever
and it was like great to just like find
anybody to talk stocks with you know
like in my circle
like they don't want to talk about what
i do it was until dave portnoy then they
wanted to talk to me
but like my friends didn't care like at
all
at all you know and actually that's why
i like dave because for the first time
like my group of friends
actually like saw something i was in
even though it was him talking [ __ ]
but they were really entertained because
they all talk [ __ ] to me too
so um so like
you know it was pretty funny so you know
that's why i love what you're doing you
know and that's why i i do these things
too and support a lot of different
people who are bringing finance and i
think
interesting viewpoints out there you
know you've you've interviewed some
really interesting people i watched a
few of them
and and and i think it's very valuable
you know
podcasting is becoming a big thing now
you know
absolutely well look we appreciate you
coming on where can people find you
on the internet or find out more about
uh gerber kawasaki
well you know gerberkawasaki.com of
course you can just
put my name in search there's plenty um
but i'm at
akurbakawasaki uh and we're on instagram
and follow us on instagram or or twitter
and if you have financial questions or
need advice that's what we do
at gerber kawasaki we work with anybody
we don't have minimums
um send me an email uh ross gerber
kawasaki.com happy to help you out
um and you know i uh once again i
appreciate your time
and and the thoughtfulness of your
interview and
and you know i appreciate the audience
for listening to me ramble i talk a lot
so hopefully i didn't talk too much but
it's an hour and a half of me rambling
but people are excited to hear this one
so
thanks so much for doing it we'll do it
again in the future yeah thank you
thank you take care